all right fourth video in five days and
um i've been getting an absolute litany
of support on this including um four
total views and zero total comments so
the motivation is strong i'm currently
showing more commitment to this channel
than most guys are to their wives so
with this in mind it's time to finish up
replication so we can eventually just
get to partitioning transactions and
then we can finally do a database
comparison
so okay let's go ahead and get ourselves
into leaderless replication
okay so today we're going to be doing
leaderless replication which is the
third type of replication that i will be
discussing
just to give it a quick overview instead
of doing what you do in multi-leader
replication where rights are still only
going to one place and reads are only
coming from one place rights are
actually going to be sent to every
single replica in parallel and reads are
going to be taken from every single
replica in parallel or at least a
certain amount of them
the point is that unlike single leader
and multi-leader replication
we're dealing with a lot of network
calls at once here
okay so you know obviously i've just
said that rights are going to go to a
bunch of places at once so it would be
great if um you know we can write every
single node at a time let's assume there
are like 100 nodes in our cluster and we
want to write all of them but the matter
of fact is that a lot of these writes
are probably going to fail so how can we
keep data up to date especially just
because a lot of times a write is going
to get to one place before it does
another
okay well there are two ways of keeping
data up to date the first is
anti-entropy so we'll discuss that
quickly
anti-entropy is literally just a
background process that looks at
multiple nodes and they're stored values
so let's assume we're using a key value
store and for every single key in the
database we're going to have a version
number of how many times that key has
been updated and so anti-entropy is
saying use the background process look
at two nodes and um you know replace the
the outdated values on given nodes with
the more updated values that it can find
on other nodes
okay so anti-entropy is one way of doing
things that not all leaderless databases
actually use but what most of them do
certainly use is read repair so the
point of read repair is like i mentioned
when you do a read you're actually
querying from multiple databases at once
and it's likely going to be the case
that if these databases have older data
we want to make sure that we then update
those databases with older data with the
data from the newer database
so as you can see in the diagram below i
want to find the value of key jordan you
can see in database 1 that i'm sexy
database 2 i'm cute and in database 3
i'm mid however the most recent version
is going to be the one with version
number 20.
so keeping this in mind let's go ahead
and say i make an actual read so i'm
going to take the arg max of all those
version numbers and then you know use
that to find the corresponding value so
since 20 is the highest version number
that means that the result is that
jordan equals sexy and from my client
now i'm going to concurrently write that
value back to database 2 and database 3
so you can see that it's now updated
such that they're all having the proper
value
okay so the issue here though is that
what if we're making a bunch of parallel
reads however none of the databases that
we're reading from actually have the
most up-to-date data
this is where something called the
quorum comes in so imagine we have
some sort of leaderless replication
schema and within that there are n
database nodes okay so now i mentioned
that when you write you write
to a certain amount of nodes in parallel
let's say that the client only receives
something saying they're right was
successful if at least w nodes are
written to so w let's just call that a
variable for now and suppose also that a
client only sees their read as being
successful if at least our nodes are
read from so we have these three um
these three variables n w and r
so now we know that if w plus r is
greater than n so if the the nodes that
i have to be able to write to to have
successful write and the nodes that i
have to be able to read from to have a
successful read sum up to more than the
number of nodes in the actual database
pool itself
we know that one of the nodes that we'll
be reading from has one of the most
updated values and then we can use read
repair to update the other ones so
typically what you would do is you'd set
n to be an odd number so let's say n is
7 and then w and r n plus 1 over 2. so
that would mean that w and r are 4 in
this case if w and r4 and n is seven
that means we can tolerate up to three
replica failures because we could still
be able to successfully write to four
nodes and also read from four nodes
okay to just illustrate this in case the
the math that i just said doesn't
instantly resonate let's use that
example i just mentioned of seven
replicas with w equals four and r equals
four so let's say initially i try to
write to all seven of these replicas but
only four of them work so i'm going to
circle those four nodes that now have
the updated value
now let's say i'm going to read from
four nodes no matter which four nodes
i'd pick to read from at least one of
them is going to have the updated value
i could circle any of the four and it is
going to be the case that one of them is
going to be in that white circle
so as you can see i've chosen these four
and in this case two of them have the
most updated value and then i can read
repair the rest
the thing is though even though quorums
give this illusion of a strongly
consistent system where every single
time you can get the most up-to-date
value it's not actually the case that
that's always right
why is that well let's say we try to
write to w nodes but we end up only
writing w minus one nodes so we're not
able to write to those four nodes we can
only write to three
the client doesn't see that their right
was successful in fact they get a
message saying that their right failed
however the issue with this is that
those nodes that they did successfully
write to are not going to roll back so
now we have an incorrect write that's
actually been propagated on a few of the
nodes and it's kind of unclear what we
should do there should we try and roll
that back eventually should we keep it
because then there might be read repair
and that value might get propagated
along it's kind of unclear and it puts
the database in an inconsistent state
okay two is that if you restore a failed
node with an up-to-date key value pair
from an older node then now that node is
no longer going to have an up-to-date
key and value and that quorum parameter
of w which you might have satisfied
earlier on a right but then once the
node crashes and comes back up is no
longer satisfied now only w minus one
nodes have the correct value and there's
no guarantee you're going to read the
most correct value anymore
three is that you can still have right
conflicts i'll demonstrate a race
condition right after this that can
happen even using quorums and as a
result it can lead to an inconsistent
state in the database and four is
something called sloppy quorums which
i'll discuss in a little bit
okay so here's the example of a right
conflict let's say that me and my angry
ex-girlfriend are both on facebook and
we're both posting because we're we're
you know flustered
i'm trying to tell everyone i'm sexy
she's trying to tell everyone i'm ugly
so i'm going to write to both databases
at once because this is a leaderless
configuration
okay she's also going to be doing the
same so what first happens is that my
first right is going to reach database
one first and as you can see that has
version number one for the key jordan of
sexy where she says that i'm ugly
however our rights become interleaved it
just so happens to be the case that my
right to database 2 gets there after her
right to database 2 and my right to
database 1 gets there before her right
to database 1. so now we have two
conflicting values where database 1
thinks that the version
the version value of 2 for jordan is
ugly and db2 thinks the version value of
2 for jordan is sexy so when the
anti-entropy process or read repair
comes back it doesn't know which is
actually the correct value they actually
have the same version number which is
pretty problem problematic um and as a
result of this this you know problem
right here we're going to have to use
conflict resolution algorithms like we
discussed in the multi-leader
replication video those still apply here
okay now onwards to sloppy quorums so
here's an example i've provided where i
am a software engineer at facebook and
let's say we have a cluster of 99
database replicas where all of my
profile data is going to be stored and
this is my profile data other users
profile data etc etc and we've chosen to
have a quorum of w equals 50 and r
equals 50. like i've been saying we
should do
however let's say all of the 99 profile
nodes have crashed so now we can no
longer satisfy those quorum conditions
and i can no longer write to the profile
and as a result of that
you know the service might go down
however you know pretty cheekily of me
i've decided that just so the data stays
durable and just so rights can go
through
that i am going to reroute all of those
profile rights to
databases that would actually be holding
the facebook messenger data
so now the rights are going to a
different place than they would normally
however they're still durable the stuff
that i'm writing is going to be there
but if i'm going to end up reading from
those profile replicas once they come
back up i'm actually not going to see
the changes i made until eventually we
can perform something called a hinted
handoff and transfer all the data back
to the correct replicas
okay
in conclusion even though leaderless
replication isn't terribly hard to
reason about
it can work quite well in practice
using cross data center solutions so
basically you know if i want to run a
quorum with a cross data center solution
let's say i have 100 total nodes in the
system and 10 data centers and 10 nodes
per data center i might set the right
parameter to equal 10 or something
however again that means that you have
to read from a ton of nodes so read
becomes very slow because you have to do
a ton of reads in parallel and possibly
even perform read repair
in addition even though again like
rights are going to be faster here you
still have to reason about right
conflicts in the same way that you would
with multi-leader replication
and then finally quorums are not perfect
for all of the reasons i just discussed
even though it seems like they might
provide strong consistency between race
conditions sloppy quorums and the fact
that writes don't actually get rolled
back when they fail
quorums do not actually provide a
completely consistent database system so
as a result leaderless replication can
be very very good for achieving high
right throughput however it does lead to
some issues when it comes to consistency
across